their bags apart and they've paid for
their tickets but this family won't be
traveling anytime soon
nearly all domestic and international
travel in Indonesia is now on hold until
June I always travel before Eid it's the
only time I can see my family I'm sad
but there is nothing we can do we must
follow the government's instructions on
a normal day a station like this one
would be packed with people and it would
be even busier in the lead-up to Eid
that won't happen this year stopping
people from travelling to their
hometowns should help so the spread of
the virus but it also brings new
challenges for those who've lost their
income and say they can no longer afford
life in Indonesia's big cities hours
before the ban came in this was the
scene at one Jakarta bus depot social
distancing gave way to desperation
thousands of people tried to get out of
the capital before it was too late
because of the announcement from the
president about the travel ban many
people panicked Jakarta is the epicenter
of the Kovach 19 outbreak in Indonesia
and these travelers could spread the
virus to provinces with no proper health
facilities but many here feel they have
no choice anyway bolo is one of them
millions of low-income earners have lost
their jobs because of the virus the
factory Eddy works out is shut
indefinitely his rent is $50 each month
and he can't afford that now the corona
virus outbreak has made this Ramadhan
different to previous years I lost my
job I'm very sad I can't live in Jakarta
without a job I can't afford it so I
decided to go home before the ban this
virus hasn't just disrupted the annual
homecoming of millions but their
livelihoods
- Jessica Washington al-jazeera Jakarta